on va se reparler de smartphones
aujourd'hui je vous ai pas mal parler
d'eux au pot en ce début d'année parce
qu'ils ont vraiment bossé sur la gamme
finepix 2 qui est top
on va se parler aujourd'hui de la gamme
à chez au pot avec un tout nouveau
smartphone qui est arrivé c'est le au
pot à 72 smartphone entrée milieu de
gamme plutôt bien qu'il fait de jolies
promesses
on va regarder si ce au pot à 72 est
fait pour vous on va regarder quels sont
les promesses qu'il fait est ce qu'ils
les tiens qu'est ce qu'ils proposent et
jolie tout de suite sur un tarif qui est
très cool on est à 2 159 euros
et je vous le dis dès maintenant comme
ça vous serez tous parce que jusqu'au 19
juillet alors je sais peut-être que vous
ramenez pas cette vidéo à ce moment là
mais en tout cas si vous la regardez des
lancements dédiés bus jusqu'au 19
juillet vous avez 20 euros de remise
savent où le sort 239 euros dans toutes
les bonnes crémeries d'ailleurs ça vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description et puisqu'on parle
de ça si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à
la chaîne vous invite à le faire
pourquoi me direz-vous déjà parce que je
voulais parler effectivement du tout
d'actualité smartphone technologies
monde connecté ordinateur et compagnie
il ya peu à plein de choses mais
également parce que vous parle de vous
je vous parle de votre vie numérique des
bonnes pratiques comment optimiser la
batterie de votre smartphone
est-ce que c'est dangereux de dormir à
côté sur smartphone et de plein d'autres
sujets qui vont arriver dans les temps à
venir donc vous cliquez juste rond sur
le bouton rouge claque vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié et
vous saurez tout avec une prochaine
vidéo sortir voilà la boîte au pot à 72
bon très classique on a des couleurs qui
sont assez chatoyant c'est tout mignon
vous le voyez dans tout de suite la
config la c 4 gigas de ram plus 100 m
giga de stockage on va approfondir côté
de fiche technique tout à l'heure je
voulais vous montrer là bas parce que je
la trouve bien réussi et voilà
maintenant le smartphone en lui alors
vous le verrez pas si vous allez vous
rendre compte avec les reflets mais il a
tendance à prendre les traces de doigts
c'est pas anormal c'est normal puisque
de toute façon la plupart des
smartphones prennent les traces de
doigts c'est un smartphone qu'il faudra
bien protégé avec une coque de
protection si vous voulez éviter les
déconvenues
mais bon rien de dia déconnante ce côté
là alors il existe deux couleurs on va
voir nous en tout cas en france et le
noir twilight et celui là vous avez des
petits reflet pas toujours évidente s'en
rendre compte comme ça et vous avez
également le
violet aurore que moi je n'ai pas en
tout cas c'est un smartphone qui n'est
pas très lourd 192 g ce qui est très
sympa c'est que vous avez un lecteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est situé
juste ici sur la tranche qui fait que
vous le prenez vous posez votre doigt et
vous arrivez directement son smartphone
déverrouiller ça c'est très très cool
autre point qui est un peu sympa du
point de vue du design c'est que le dow
est incurvé sur le côté là pas si vous
en rendrez bien content qui est cool
c'est que vous avez une petite prise
jack qui conservait donc ça c'est bien
de la recharge en usb ses haut parleurs
micro ça c'est sympa tiroirs de cartes
signe que vous avez ici bouton de volume
c'est pas un format mini on a quand même
ici un écran de 6,5 pouces alors ici
c'est un écran lcd c'est du tft c'est
pas une dali ps mais par contre on a
bien un écran full hd 2400 par 1080
pixels avec un écran qui occupent 90 5%
de la face avant alors effectivement on
va avoir une bordure en bas qui va être
assez grande mais une fois de plus sur
un certain 10 coûte 259 euros
il n'y a rien de bien des conneries là
dessus pour voir son positionnement on
est vraiment sur un adn multimédia ce
qui va être intéressant pour l'aspect
multimédia sais que vous allez avoir une
expérience un peu plus immersive avec
des haut-parleurs stéréo sur un
smartphone à 259 euros ça c'est plutôt
rare donc il faut souligner si vous
voulez profiter d'une expérience au
casque vous avez votre prise jack ça je
vous l'aï déjà dit et en plus de ça vous
avez du bluetooth 5.0 pour venir écouter
avec un casque sans fil au tango gap
pour l'expérience multimédia tout cas
purement sonore ya vraiment de quoi
faire on aura un son qui est
effectivement assez médium on va pas
avoir un style complètement dingue on
l'est aussi sur un smartphone c'est pas
normal qu'elle soit plus 259 euros les 2
les haut parleurs ici qui fonctionne et
vous avez le deuxième en façade leçon à
pâques du ska qui est équilibré mais une
fois de plus 259 euros et ça c'est
vraiment la bonne nouvelle de ce
smartphone qui dans sa catégorie de prix
reste très bon pour le côté multimédia
aux potiers coup là il faut aussi
stipulé si vous allez pouvoir regarder
tout votre contenu multimédia que ce
soit à netflix my canal distinct plus
ces compagnies en full hd côté
performances pures et dures vous annonce
martin qui marche très bien qui est
réactif on a retrouvé ses accents
dragonne 665 4 gigas de ram c'est la lp
dernière 4 x 128 jia de stockage ou les
montres tout à l'heure sur la boîte
c'est écrit ici c'est un bel argument
marketing onu fs de poing et une fois de
plus par rapport à son positionnement
tarifaire sera parfaitement la fête
on a également une très grosse batterie
de 5000 milliampères heures c'est
toujours un peu l'idée si vous voulez
quand on arrive sur des smartphones dans
cette gamme de prix de jouer vraiment
sur l'autonomie grosse batterie de 5000
médiapart heures qui en fonction de vos
usages autour de vous de ce que vous
allez en faire qui vous permettra de
garder votre smartphone allumé en vie
jusqu'à deux jours ci vous bourriner si
vous allez à fond et vous jouer tout le
temps vous passez votre temps à râler
des vidéos une fois de plus ces deux
jours vous les aurez pas mais si vous en
avez un usage raisonnable et bien deux
jours vous les aurez sans aucun problème
et ça c'est bien et si un moment vous
arrivez en fin de course
parce que vous l'avez beaucoup plus
utilisés en milieu de journée bien vous
avez une charge rapide de 18 watts qui
vous permettra de le recharger de 0 à 50
% en 45 minutes
alors ici pas de vous que chaz mais
néanmoins chargeur rapide dont certains
très très bien la faire on tourne ici
sur color os 7.1
alors je vous ai déjà parlé de colorer
ça marche bien c'est très pratique
complètement adapté ce que je vous
conseille de faire lorsque vous
récupérez votre smartphone c'est si vous
l'achetez bien évidemment aux as et en
affichage et luminosité et vous venez
régler ici la température couleurs
l'écran gardez vous l'avez là vous
mettez sur plus chaud parce que par
défaut l'écran d'avoir pendant attirer
un peu trop sur le bleu vous venez le
passé sur le show sa vie un petit peu
cassé ces faits bleuté ça vient
réchauffer ses biens et si vraiment vous
voulez venir protéger vos yeux vous avez
l'option protection des yeux qui va
venir le jaunir davantage
ça peut être pas mal ça tire un petit
peu sur un côté un peu marre sonné ça
c'est vraiment à vous de voir
vous avez un autre sombre si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez venir active et ça
c'est vraiment à vous voir ce que vous
voulez faire à savoir qu'ici comme on
est sûr us et déco n'est pas sûr du oled
un pixel noire des phases 1 pixel et
allemands on va pas venir économiser de
l'énergie là dessus à la différence du
oled ou effectivement le noir c'est un
pixel est un donc on économise de
l'énergie
à côté de ça toute la partie os et bien
fonctionne bien que leurs os 7 points
j'en ai déjà parlé et vous tournez en
plus là dessus sur un android 10 autant
vous dire tout écouler en plus pour la
partie logicielle toucas intéressant
c'est que vous allez utiliser les icônes
google notamment pour les appels pour
les messages également pour l'agenda
donc si vous êtes vous
aimant habitué à google voulait étudier
des absents contre google eh bien voyez
elles sont déjà installés par défaut
donc ça c'est plutôt cool auto qui est
vraiment important aujourd'hui sur un
smartphone c'est la partie photo vous le
voyez à l'arrière vous avez pas moins de
quatre capteurs on est vraiment dans la
tendance actuelle
vous allez avoir un capteur principal de
40 8 mégapixels tout bref 1.7 et si
c'est pas un capteur sony on est ici un
capteur samsung on se retrouve juste
avec un ultra grand-angle de 8
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.2 avec un
champ de vision 219 degrés je vais vous
montrer les résultats dans quelques
instants et ensuite vous avez deux
caméra de 2 mégapixels
ils travaillent de concert pour le mode
portrait tandis qu'à l'avant dans le
petit rond d'un petit point sans vous
avez là vous avez une caméra c'est le
fit de 16 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0
la partie logicielle photo vous
connaissez ya rien de bien déconner ça
fonctionne très très bien ou bien filmé
en 4k jusqu'à 30 images par seconde en
1080p à 30 images par seconde vous avez
un mode nuit de la photo du portrait
plus vous avez pas mal de petites
options on n'est pas sur un photophone
de dingue je vous montre une fois de
plus le résultat dans quelques secondes
mais pour faire quelques petits
souvenirs vous êtes bien vous avez votre
ultra grand temps qui est là vous pouvez
monter jusqu'à un zoom x 10 si vous le
souhaitez sinon x 1 x 2 ça me semble en
tout cas ce qui est plus intéressant
voilà donc quelques photos avec le au
pot à 72 on commence avec la caméra
principale dans l'ensemble ça fonctionne
on n'est pas sur un photophone n'aura
pas des photos qui seront aussi bonnes
que trouve à bord avec un phénix de neo
ou alors avec un pack de kro
mais le résultat est somme toute assez
correcte elle l' ultra grand-angle est
un peu moins bon on perd en saturation
perd en précision c'est un peu déformant
c'est pas génial
le zoom x 2 fera la ferme et des combats
au delà avec deux fois cinq ans plus
tard beaucoup de bruit ça lisse c'est
pas terrible et il faut 10 il est
vraiment pas beau pas qualitatif et pas
exploitable caméra principale voyez on
devrait voir les détails sur la fleur se
sont tout à fait correctes x 2 c'est pas
ouf mais ça fonctionne
face à une seule puce on oublie faut 10
on oublie complètement et luttera
grand-angle permettra de capturer
quelques souvenirs et notamment des
bâtiments lorsque vous avez beaucoup
lumière la caméra principale charles
très bien le contre jour pareil sur le x
2 1 x 5 c'est justement le problème
l'ultra grand angle fronhof une fois de
plus caméra principale on va pas avoir
le meilleur appareil photo et on le voit
ici c'est un petit peu cramé dans cette
zone de soleil soit 2 sa phrase taf
phase 5 c'est pas beau et luttera
grand-angle n'ira pas trop mal mais une
fois que vous voyez on à défaut de
saturation et au niveau des zones
surexposées c'est pas terrible
la caméra de 5,6
donne un résultat qui est somme toute
assez correcte elle a légèrement
tendance à venir lycées au niveau de la
peau mais c'est pas surprenant le mode
portrait des tours bhutto pas mal
il a un petit peu de mal ici au niveau
de la montre où ça s'est vraiment
complexifier on le voit la touques il ya
vraiment un visage un peu trop lisse et
hanifi qui est pas naturelle
il a adopté le mode portrait on en fait
pas beau et dans les airs vous avez un
petit peu moins de lumière vous avez
l'expo long de dix secondes vous le
posez sur un pied sortira quelque chose
même s'il paraît non pas extraordinaire
mais il faut de plus c'est pas
s'inquiéter pour sa hotte points qui
écoule vous avez essayé de quoi stocker
double nano sin +4 microsd pour venir
augmenter la capacité de stockage de vos
smartphones un smartphone qui a dû fc et
les informations d'as voyages tout de
suite j'ai noté là-dessus à départager
les trois parker vous avez un d'aspects
de 0,4 181 watts par kilogramme corps de
0,9 117 et membre de 2,194 watts par
kilogramme
ici vous n'avez absolument aucune
certification eal pénis et 67 mai 68
mais une fois de plus sur un smartphone
dans cette gamme de prix ça me paraît
normal puisque notification ip coûte de
l'argent et cela se répercutera sur le
prix du smartphone et si on veut rester
concurrentiels et bien il ya pas
certification et autre point qui est
intéressant au pot a pu réunir sa
hotline en france pour le consommateur
français qui se trouvent à tourcoing
donc si vous êtes à tourcoing que vous
passez un coup de fil sachez que les
personnes qui vous répondent ne sont pas
très loin de chez vous pour les autres
vous savez que ça pourquoi donc ça c'est
plutôt bien comme je le disais c'est un
smartphone qui coûte 259 euros vous avez
une remise en ce moment et ce jusqu'au
19 juillet moi personnellement je trouve
intéressant au pot nous fait une belle
proposition dans cette gamme de prix
on a un smartphone qui est optimisé pour
le côté multimédia et c'est pour moi un
des usages les plus importants les
photos sont là caméra principale on va
pas aller aussi loin que si vous aviez
un capteur sony b14 samsung fera très
bien la faire on va pas chercher à aller
zoomer loin on va pas avoir ici le
meilleur photophone ne va pas voir ici
le meilleur écran monaco chose qui est
équilibré pour avoir une bonne
expérience pour profiter d'un bon
smartphone à moins de 160 euros et que
souvent tout cas on est à vous de me
dire vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas on commenté comment vous
le trouvez ce propos à 72 est-ce qu'il
peut vous tenter est-ce qu'il vous tente
est ce qui vous choque est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu un smartphone de au pot et
est ce que si c'est pas le cas
celui-là prévenu permettent en tout cas
de commencer l'expérience avec en fond
tout ça en bas on commente a surtout
extrêmement rapidement et croyez moi
la taxe ne s'arrête jamais beaucoup
d'amour les gros bisous et à très
bientôt
quelqu'un
[Musique]